- Tell your mama, hey
tell your mama I said hi.
Yeah I work with her.
(knocking on door)
- Oh, let's get this party started.
My single bros.
I am a married dude, but now it is time
for me to hang with my single bros.
- What's up Jason?
Yeah, you like that you little bitch?
Huh?
Yeah, how's your mama's dick taste?
Ha ha.
- He's talkin' to an 11 year old.
- That's awesome, fill me in,
what did I miss?
What did I miss so far?
- Ah Jason, you didn't miss much.
I mean, we've just been
hangin' out, you know,
oh Michael made some prank calls earlier.
- Yeah I made this old lady cry.
- You did?
You did?
Ah I can't believe I missed it.
Ah God, you guys are so much fun.
It's like, you've got to
be my coolest friends.
- We are your coolest friends, man
and you have missed out but tonight,
miss out no more.
We got that Pinot Grigio wine,
we got that brie for you
and we got back episodes of The Bachelor,
that's straight J Nash life.
- Yes, yes, Pinot Grigio
and back episodes of The Bachelor,
and I need to be home in one hour.
Ohhh, pahhh, pohh,
so, guys night.
- I guess you had fun, huh?
What did you, what'd you guys get into?
What'd you do?
- We made two hilarious prank calls
that were so funny.
- Wow, J, I just, I
don't know if I can think
of anything that sounds cooler to me
than a bunch of bros, in their 30's,
making prank phone calls.
- Well they were pretty funny.
You'll have to hear them to decide that.
- Mmm, I doubt it.
Listen, I've been dealing
with this all night,
I've been trying to get Taylor into that
Springing Daisies Academy, you know?
And it's just impossible.
Do you know this guy, Arthur Ruthledge?
- He's a black guy, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, well why don't
you let me handle that?
- What, handle it?
What are you gonna do?
How are you gonna handle it?
- Ah, where'd I just come from?
Hanging out with my two black friends.
Huh?
Black people love me.
- Please, stop.
- Oh I'm sorry, how many
black friends do you have?
How many?
- You know, you know my friends, right?
- How about, let's count them up.
Go ahead.
- [Wife] Look, I just don't have ...
- No, zero, you have zero.
- You know, no, it's not
like, a choice I've made
but no, I don't have a black friend.
I don't have any.
- So, don't hate the
game, hate the player.
- No, that's not the saying,
it's the other way around.
- The other way?
Don't hate the player, the game?
Is that how it goes?
- [Wife] Don't hate the
player, hate the game.
- Right, cause the game is
a bigger, it's much larger,
sense, so that does make sense.
You are correct.
So don't do that.
I'll handle it, black people lave me.
(door knocking)
- Arthur, thank you so
much for coming over.
Come on in.
- I have to say, I really
appreciate you reaching down.
I don't get a lot of social
calls from the other dads.
- Do you not have any friends?
- That's something I think
we should save for later
in the conversation,
when we know each other
a little better.
- Yeah, once we get to know each other
and you feel more comfortable.
You know what, we're
gonna change that today.
- I'm excited.
- Well come on in.
- All right.
This is very nice.
- Yeah, so uh, yeah, you know,
we're thinking about maybe going to
Springing Daisies next year.
- It's a great school.
- Yeah, I know your daughters go there.
- Yes, yes.
- Yeah, that's really great.
Hey, you know what I
got down in the garage?
- [Arthur] What's that?
- I got like, a hundred
old copies of Barely Legal.
- Oh, is that a, some
sort of law magazine?
- No, no, it's uh...
- It's not about things
that are almost laws?
- No.
(chuckles)
I'm gonna show em' to you,
I'm gonna show you what it is.
You're gonna be surprised.
(laughs)
Come on, have a seat.
How about some video games, huh?
- Oh sure.
- Yeah we sit in the kid's chair.
Yeah, you fuckin' little piece of shit,
take that fuckin' asshole.
Yeah you little dick tease.
Your mother's fuckin' dumb, that's all.
I'm not dumb.
They don't care, they're not real kids.
They're on the Internet.
It doesn't count.
You're stupid, you're 11.
You're 11 years old, you know nothing.
You know nothing about the world
and you have to ask your
parents to do something.
And you're dumb.
You're dumb, and you're
probably gonna go nowhere.
And people say this is
the best part of your life
and really, it is
and look, and think about how bad it is.
Say something nasty dude.
- I'm not gonna...
- Be mean to the 11 year olds.
- That doesn't make any sense to do that.
- No, it's fun.
- They need positive role models.
- Arthur, Arthur come here, come here.
- I can come back when
you're off the phone.
- No, no, no, no, I'm doing a prank call.
Come here, come here, come
here, come here, shhhh.
- But who are you calling?
- I'm calling the pizza
place, I'm doing a prank call.
- Why would you do that?
- Hello?
Hi, yes, hi, this is Sylvester Stallone.
- But you're not Sylvester Stallone.
- Hello, yeah, I would
like to order a pizza.
Yeah, yeah, this is
really Sylvester Stallone.
- This is an awful way to be
wasting that person's time.
- Yeah, it was good to talk to you too.
- Why would you, they're
gonna make a pizza.
- Let me get a, let me get a.
- Actually I'm hungry so if you...
- Let me get a 16 inch pizza.
- If you're ordering...
- With mushrooms.
- Yeah, mushrooms, half mushrooms.
- No, I'm not, I'm not
really getting a pizza.
I'm not really getting a pizza.
- They're gonna make a pizza, I'll go get,
I'll go pick it up.
- Yeah, what's that?
- You can't, this is awful.
- So now he knows, you fucked it up.
(sizzling)
- Those steaks look really good.
- You ever think about
leaving your family?
- I think it's time that I go.
- Yeah, probably so.
- Nice to meet you, Jason.
- Good to meet you Arthur.
Well, that didn't go well.
- Wait Jason, so you thought,
just because Michael and I are such fun,
that this random black dude that you met
was also gonna be fun?
- Yeah, I just assumed
that he would be the same way, I guess.
- Cause we're all fun?
- Yeah, you guys are fun.
Aren't all black people fun?
- We're not oompa loompas,
man, that's racist.
- It's not racist, it's a positive thing.
I feel positively.
- Yeah, well it spit in
your face, didn't it?
And I hate to break it to you,
but most black people are boring.
- [Jason] Really?
- Yeah.
- You know my cousin,
he's a black dude, right?
All he does is spend his
Friday nights sittin' at home
watching Sex in the City reruns.
And building up his
character on Second Life.
- Jason, most of the black kids
I went to high school with,
they're into Will Smith now.
And not his movies, his music.
- That's terrible.
- [Michael] Yeah.
I mean, this is the guy,
this is the guy that was gonna
get my kid into the school
and I blew it.
- Well listen, take Michael and I
and we'll go talk to him with you.
- Yeah.
- What?
Take my two black friends
and go over to see
the other black guy that I know?
- Yes.
- And do what?
- Talk.
- You'd do that for me?
- Yeah.
- Of course.
- Is that him right there?
- Yeah.
- Don't worry, we'll take care of it.
- Junk, junk, junk.
- Arthur, it's Jason Nash,
- Jason fuckin' Nash,
- Yeah.
- What's wrong with you, huh?
- What's happening?
- Let his kid in your school.
- [Arthur] I don't have much control.
- Hit him, hit him.
- Ahhhh, yeah.
So break, break.
- [Jason] Guys, don't do that.
- Break out this..
- [Jason] What are you doin?
Why are you takin' your pants off?
- I thought you said.
- No, no, just talk to him.
Arthur, please don't
tell anyone about this.
This never happened, please, please.
- I'm gonna tweet this,
hashtag blackguys.
- No, no.
- Well, what's your name, I'll follow you.
- Twitter, Arthur.
- Hey get picture, get a picture.
- Big Arthur.
- [Jason] This is Steve
and this is Michael,
these are my friends.
- Stay black, man.
- [Jason] These are my black friends.
- Yeah, tweet that.
(laughs)
- [Jason] Okay Arthur, I'm
really sorry, are you okay?
- No, I'm not okay.
- We should go.
We should go.
- It's a good picture.
(chuckles)
- Did you see his eyes?
Did you see his eyes?
(laughs)